foreign
the comedy Powerhouse that is why Mage
Studios continues to make big moves in
the podcasting space most recently with
the addition of another brand new show
on their Network that premiered earlier
today hello and welcome to the very
first episode of first date the show's
description reads hosts Lauren Compton
invites celebrity guests on a first date
to decide if they're dateable basically
it sounds like a sex-fueled version of
are you garbage first date will be the
fifth show on the ymh network joining
the ranks of two bears one cave your
mom's house Dr Drew after dark where my
mom's at and the Danny Brown Show all
five of these shows are hosted by
familiar faces in the ymh universe
whether that be Burton Tom Christina P
Danny Brown or even Dr Drew so who's the
host of this new show Lauren Compton is
a comedian and vital content creator
who's here live on our show right now to
tell us a little bit more about herself
and why mage's newest podcast Lauren
thank you so much for being here yeah of
course thanks for having me so my first
question is a broad one but how did
first date come about as far as meeting
Tom and Christina and just getting
connected to the ymh brand so
after one of my my viral videos came out
I think it was the one where I was
walking to the mailbox and I get hotter
and hotter and hotter that video came
out and about a week later I got an
email from ymh and they were asking me
if originally if I just wanted to go on
Dr Drew and then I went on Dr Drew and
we had such a good time and then they
asked me if maybe I'd be interested in
hosting a show at ymh and I was like oh
wow that's actually a really cool idea
and then this was all about a year ago
and it took us a year so it's been in
the works for a really long time I've
kind of compared it to like the dating
version of are you garbage in a way like
they find out if your favorite
comedian's trashy or classy and you find
out if they're dateable what kind of
experiences in the dating world have you
been through have you endured that makes
you the perfect host for the show I
do this because I'm very opinionated and
I feel like I come from a pretty
balanced idea of what is right and wrong
but you'd be surprised the people that
I've interviewed how they don't give a
[__]
um you know and like like Tom that I
have an episode that comes out tomorrow
with Tom Segura then he was telling me
like one of the I guess this is like
just a little sneak preview of what we
talk about but I asked him I was like
you know when you were single how would
you go about dating people like this was
that was I'm sure like you're so old
like that was before dating apps you
know like how did you go about finding
people and he was like well I used to go
to acting classes and I would pluck
actresses and like I'm like Tom that's a
red flag
so we have things like that in the show
where people are sort of alluding to
their like dark secrets and then I call
them out and then at the end of the show
we count how many red flags they have we
decide and by we I mean I
okay
so you're joining a studio uh that has
one of the most rabid and die hard fan
bases anywhere on the internet has there
been pressure felt like joining that
family have you gotten any early
feedback from the ymh community announce
the media and I shouldn't read the
comments minutes I know better than that
you know I'm like I should know better
but for some reason a part of me was
like I'm gonna go read the comments
today and you know they're like oh she
goes on Dr Drew and she has big tits
this is Tom's doing you know and I'm
like God damn it like I work really hard
to have like personality for you people
and all you can see is my boobs but I
feel like the the show itself is so
entertaining so I'm just hoping that
maybe they stir up so much around the
show where they're like this show is
gonna be [__] and hopefully that makes
people want to actually tune in to find
some validation and the [__] that
they're saying and see that there's
actually more to the show than they
thought but you know I mean that's the
internet for you like the internet just
a bunch of [__] trolls
and then
uh everyone has been over the moon about
the show Tom has been so nice to me
Christina's been so nice to me they're
all really excited I mean we had a set
built this wonderful designer his name
is Marcus Laporte he does Quentin
Tarantino's set design damn he's a
freelancer now and he built the set and
we talked about it for months like
setting the scene making it Moody having
like a whole vibe as if you were on a
date so a lot has really gone in to
creating the whole concept and making it
look good and feel good and it's it's
not just another podcast that were that
they've thrown together like there's
been a whole lot of love that's like
gone into this yeah so you're talking
about your new bosses Tom and Christina
a little bit there who do you think is
less dateable or least dateable between
the two of them
hands down
it's funny too because Christina watched
the podcast as I did it with Tom and the
whole time she was just like
[__] and so and then I went on
Christina's podcast right after that and
we talked a little bit about it on there
and she's like man I can't wait to get
on that podcast and like talk about our
dating life because she's like because
what he says and what I say are like
very different relations
well speaking of getting guests one
final question for you here uh before
the show is officially started I guess
who is one dream interview that you've
had for the Show comedian or not if you
could have anyone in the hot seat to ask
them dating questions who would it be I
have been begging the studio to let my
gynecologist come on
I I feel like talking to the guy that
looks at my vagina for fun that is the
kind of person that I really want to
talk to and find out like what is it
like because it's like it's supposed to
be what is it like to date the person
across for me and I'm so curious what it
would be like to date someone that's a
man that just looks at vagina on vagina
like how do you
you know I'd be so insecure I'd be like
how does my vagina look compared to all
the other ones like you know so I don't
know I think that in my [__] up little
world that's where that's who I would
like to talk to that is such an
unexpected answer I was expecting like
uh Joe Rogan or some crazy well thank
you so much Lauren for coming on the
show thank you for being a part of uh
this joke World comedy news update and
uh your show's out right now on the ymh
channel we can go check it out there
anything else uh you want to plug while
you're here yeah you guys can find me
anywhere at
Iowa but I would say that the first date
podcast is my new my new jam so you can
find that at first date show so that's
that's the handle for that on pretty
much everything except Facebook Facebook
I think it's like first date with Lauren
or something they couldn't get it so but
if you follow me or you follow that
Instagram like it'll all lead you to the
same place awesome sounds good thank you
Lauren in other news Andrew Schultz
crash Ticketmaster's entire server last
week during pre-sale for his upcoming
show at Scotiabank Arena selling all 13
000 seats in less than two hours the
official start to my new tour is going
to be in Toronto on September 30th at
the Scotia Bank Arena I swear
[__] Raptors play that's where
the [__] paintball Leafs play
that's where Disney on Ice is at demand
was so high from Comedy fans to witness
Schultz's first time playing an arena
that he was able to add a second show
right away which to No Surprise also
sold out immediately unbelievable 26 000
tickets under 48 Hours Toronto you got
me feeling like burner boy I'm
incredibly grateful the life tour has
officially begun if the infamous tour
showed us anything these shows are going
to be incredible the pure spectacle that
Andrew Schultz was able to bring to last
year's theater tour was so well done
that you gotta assume he's got something
huge up his sleeve with this jump to
Arenas plus the demand for these two
shows makes me think the life tour will
likely be all Arena shows or at least
big theaters which is not only going to
be super cool for comedy fans but also
would add Andrew Schultz to the rare
list of comedians who've sold out Arenas
all across the world guest spots from
last week RFK was the guest on The Joe
Rogan Experience ymh had on Mateo Lane
Mateo was also the guest on Whiskey
Ginger Sam Talent was on Dr Drew after
dark two Bears won cave was Burton Tom
and Burton Kyle Kinane was on we might
be drunk kill Tony this week was with
David tell and Jeff Ross Caroline
banyuich was on take her shoes off
Chrissy chaos had on Kenny Sebastian are
you garbage truck with Lil SASS and the
Adam Freeman show had on Chris Cuomo I
like dogs better than cats you see a
tiger as a cat I guess I like tiger I
don't know do you have a dog yeah what
kind Pitbull
is that true what's his name Isis show
me a picture so cute
this was actually true she's so cute oh
she's my best friend she changed my life
this makes me feel so differently about
you and I like your hair better in this
picture that's my girlfriend oh
this past weekend with the Yvonne talked
with Roseanne flagrant had on Israel out
of Sanya Matt and Shane's secret podcast
talked with Kevin ISO Chad and JT were
on the Harland Highway taste buds
battled Bomb Pop vs creamsicle Frankie
Quinones was on the Honeydew Jay Leno
was on the blocks podcast Duncan
Trussell was on where my mom's at and
Tommy Pope and Carmen Lynch were on you
know what dude and young gravy was the
guest on tigerbelly as far as new
stand-up specials are either out right
now or coming out soon the big one from
last week was Mateo Lane hair plugs and
heartache that is a hilarious 47 minutes
out right now on Mateo's YouTube channel
we also have Ali Sadiq domino effect
part 2 up over a million views on
YouTube as well Nate Craig live at the
Green Mill was uploaded to YouTube two
weeks ago and some upcoming stand-up to
look forward to the young Bulls Shane
Gillis is filming his new special this
Saturday June 24th also the fully loaded
tour is underway right now and it looks
[__] amazing the lineups are insane
the venues are incredible if you have a
chance to go experience this Festival I
would strongly recommend it guys what
are you doing in this summer here's my
pitch four weeks two weeks in June two
weeks in July we hit the road start in
New York ended the gorge cold beers
cocktails fireworks slip and slides
don't tell we're doing Arenas baseball
fields people are ripping their shirts
off it's the time of a [__] life
we've got some dope videos coming out
later this week right here on joke world
if you're a Norm McDonald fan I would
definitely recommend checking out the
video we posted over the weekend that
video will be linked on the end screen
here as well as below in the description
if you want to check it out shout out
Lauren Compton for coming on the show go
check out first date right now over on
the ymh YouTube channel and make sure to
mix it up in that comment section tell
them joke World sent you tell them I
found this video from joke world's
Channel let's see what happens if you
all did that I don't know thanks for
watching
at joke world
and the world is wrld
[Music]